welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and like a bat out of
hell the new penguin trailer is dropped
giving us our first look at the upcoming
HBO Max sorry Max show throughout this
video we're going to be talking about
all the Easter eggs comic book callbacks
and also the characters in it who could
be making a big entrance this series is
pulling heavily from the long Halloween
Dark Victory and also penguin pain and
Prejudice because we're going to be
talking about those books there will be
some spoilers for what happens in them
so if you don't want things ruined then
I'll recommend that you turn off now if
you enjoy the video please hit the
Thumbs Up Button make sure you subscribe
for breakdowns on the show when it
releases without the way a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the trailer
this
this is one of those moments
[Music]
you gotta ask yourself
what kind of Life do I want
now we begin with shots from the ending
of the Batman and get a wide shot of
Gotham in the aftermath of the Riddler's
attack that film saw him blowing up the
sea wall which flooded parts of the city
leading to a no man's land type of
aesthetic in case you haven't read that
run it basically centered around Gotham
being rocked by a gigantic earthquake
during the story cataclysm in the
aftermath of it gangs run right in the
city turning it into a sort of Escape
From New York thing Nolan sort of did
something similar in The Dark Knight
Rises after Bain blew up all the bridges
and at this point Gotham's very much on
its last legs along with major parts of
it being flooded we also have the death
of Falcone which has created a power
vacuum in the city we get shots of city
hall with a dog swimming along before we
cut to Oswald looking at a Falcone's
window and the sub-level of the Iceberg
Lounge I think this was located even
lower than the 44 below club and it's
where the gangster lived away from the
Limelight whilst the accumulated
billions from the renewal fund Oswald
standing in his window was a very
symbolic way to end the movie and it's
sure that he was after everything the
character owned and ruled over now we
could do some production shots and I
think this is the same room which
penguins are now potentially living out
of we then see a black Mars already
pulling up and this has likely been
picked due to its symbol being a trident
Gotham is of course flooded and with a
penguin being an aquatic bird we had
this idea now stretching Beyond just the
Iceberg Lounge puns now speaking of the
Iceberg Lounge we then cut to the
outside of it with penguin hobbling
along I think it's great that colindus
has affected walk throughout the trailer
and it of course gives him a waddle
similar to his namesake
win win the penguin the Iceberg Lounge
sign is also busted up and we did see
the Montage at the end of the Batman
movie that this was too damaged by the
flooding he's still working away from it
though and using this as a base to build
his Empire out of the world ain't built
for guys like us
that's why we gotta take whatever we
decide it's ours
let's call my vocals right in try to
push me out
well why are you
you ain't seen what I can do
anyway we next see what I think is a
FEMA truck being escorted through the
streets of Gotham in the next shot we
can catch penguin in his car and this is
in the rear view window all parked up
later on we see him exiting out the back
of the truck with Bima written on the
doors kind of why I'm drawing the
conclusions here avima is an insurance
company and it stands for Federal
Emergency Management agency with Gotham
being racked by floods I'm guessing that
these have been called in to help but
the gangsters might be using them as a
way to profit I think the earlier shots
are penguin possibly looking at the
truck and then scoping it out about
things in place to steal it we probably
see the other side of this later on and
it's possible that Michael Kelly's
character walks in right after they've
taken it now though we don't know this
for definite that all rumors that Kelly
will actually be playing Falcon's
consiglieri called Milos Grappa this was
a character that popped up in the long
Halloween as well and he was then later
changed up to become Falcon's bodyguard
here though they've gone back to his
roots and Kelly has of course already
started Man of Steel making this a DC
alumni appearance we then see penguin
getting held down and over the top we
can hear Kelly saying that he was
Carmine's right hand and that they
pushed him out penguin was Falcon's
right hand man in the Batman movie and
potentially grappa's making a play for
dominance he may be trying to get
revenge on penguin who was probably the
reason that he got kicked out in the
first place the next we see Shore Ag and
ashlu Hoover now remains an unnamed
character it is possible that this is
kalavidi who also featured in The Long
Halloween she was actually the sister of
Carmine and we meet another family
member not too long after in a
restaurant where he introduced to
another woman and this is Kristen
miliari who's playing Sofia Falcone
she's a big character in the comics like
like gigantic and she was introduced in
the long Halloween after she was
released from prison brought in to help
her father seize power in Gotham the end
of the book saw her getting a broken
neck and being paralyzed from the head
down a Dark Victory had a mysterious
killer known as the hangman going around
murdering people and though Sophia
appeared in a wheelchair throughout the
story this was all in a it was revealed
that she was actually just feigning
paralysis and at the end of the book we
learned she was the one carrying out the
crimes she's obviously looking to take
over her father's Empire and we see her
and penguin doing her cheers with one
another to cement their Union so fear
very much represents the dollar Falcon
accepted and as we know from the first
Batman movie Selena's the daughter he
didn't know about this could create a
pretty cool rivalry with them down the
line and in the comics it was actually
Catwoman that seemingly broke Sophia's
neck
step out of line even once I got you
like a goddamn fish
can you imagine the people saying my
name in the streets after you're gone
never mean something
the no King pentagon
[Music]
now from here we cut to what looks like
a homeless area in Gotham around a fire
we can catch two characters with the one
on the right being penguin and the one
on the left being renzi police this is
someone who pops up throughout the
teaser and penguin very much takes him
under his wing pun intended as we've
been talking about you know the
gangsters all have their right hand men
and this is clearly Penguins scrubbing
this guy out we see the pair in the next
shot loading her body into a car and
over the top of this here penguin
telling him that he'll get him like a
fish every steps out of line you see
penguin waddling to a train with him as
well and on a sign we can see this is
Dylan Ave Dylan have balls from the
comics and in the Gotham Knight game you
can actually find a batarang collectible
air as well and we then see penguin
meeting with Carmen as Jojo and this
could be Carla instead of the other
character before she does have blonde
hair which makes her look similar how
she does in the comics and therefore I'm
thinking that it might actually be her
the woman we see before might actually
be connected to the moronis and this is
why she's got penguin held down instead
of siding with him like the falcon cones
do a common also seems like she's making
an alliance with penguin and he may be
rounding up the Falcon family in order
to make the best power play now in
addition to this we know that both
Moroni and Alberto Falcone will be
appearing in the show too the former
will be played by Clancy Brown and no
doubt he's gonna want revenge for the
drops burst being pinned on him in the
first film this was seen as the biggest
drug seizure in Gotham and it led to him
going to prison for over 20 years since
then it's been exposed though that he
was in fact innocent and thus he's
likely been set free and Maroney is a
big character in the comics and during
Dark Victory he made a major power play
too he was also the character that threw
acid in Harvey Dent's face and we may
potentially see the D.A introduced in
this series now as for Alberto he was
revealed to be the holiday killer in the
long Halloween he actually faked his own
death so that he could continue his
killings and we may see something
similar happening in this series anyway
we close out with penguin killing
someone and then laughing away Colin has
really perfected this character and he's
nailed the mannerisms like this bring
him to life calling himself the new
Kingpin of Gotham we close out on a
chilling shot of his face and can see
him scheming away that wraps up the
trailer and I think it looks incredible
and when you compare this to some of the
other comic book shows we've had
recently this is Head and Shoulders
above it the tone and atmosphere are
breathtaking and it looks like a soprano
slash Godfather 2 sort of show that's
really gonna build the penguin up as
being a terrifying villain I am
wondering if Batman will cameo in this
and potentially we may see Robert
Pattinson in one form or another during
no man's land when Enterprises help to
fix Gotham and they may intervene with a
flooding crisis this appearing on the
news or something would be a cool way to
keep it connected to the world though
I'd love to see The Dark Knight
appearing in the series Once penguins
got more powerful you kinda need that
Cameo I think and we do know this is
happening one week after the events of
the movie so it makes sense so Batman to
still be prominent in Gotham either way
I really can't wait to watch it and and
obviously let me know your thoughts
below and what you think the show is
going to be like we are in a competition
right now giving away the Superman 4K
box out of three subscribers on the 15th
of April and all you have to do when the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer we pick comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on Twitter out heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the Marvels trailer which will be linked
on screen on the box right there if not
you want something more DC we've got the
Blue Beetle one as well so definitely
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for staying through the video
I've been Paul and I'll see you next
time you take care peace
foreign
[Music]